[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talk about whatever we want yes
yes we got dante back
we were just talking about how we're
[ __ ] we are [ __ ] i mean
we're just talking about you know yeah
right covet of course if not
covet then it's wildfires in california
if not wildfire california it's
arctic freezing things in in texas i
mean what else is there it's like lions
and tigers and bears oh my god
everything was behind us in 2020 and i
thought this year was supposed to be the
year where we kind of like
roll over yeah and then it's like the
rainbow after the storm no no no no no i
heard a podcast another storm
they said 2020 was the ribbon-cutting
ceremony
no 2021's gonna get worse we're [ __ ]
oh i like that analogy
i heard we're gonna see some crazy
economic collapse
why are y'all so excited about it yeah
why are you grating while you're saying
he's like
he's gonna come out because when
uh bad things happen it doesn't happen
to everyone
there's certain people that benefit from
the bad stuff yeah how can we benefit
from that bastard yeah how do we how do
we position ourselves
bitcoin a new bitcoin well if you're in
texas right now and you're on the street
selling ear muffs you'll probably make
some
bank it's not it's time to get your
hustle on it's time to get your hustle
you like wearing earmuffs no i do got a
pair i was in boston and i picked up a
pair because it was
freezing yeah i don't understand that
they're out
you could just get headphones you can't
get headphones you can't get headphones
and you could be cool it's like got uggs
in the middle of it you know
i got the ugg so it's just like oh this
is good but you can't wear them anywhere
outside of like
freezing cold weather yeah have you guys
seen the videos of texas right now where
like
so it's not just like like big bear
where you know they're used to
snow so they have like protocol there's
like a the
the truck that comes in with the shovel
so the snow just gets pushed off to the
side
they're straight up super because people
can't even get food so they're straight
up supermarkets the parking lot
is just froze over here and [ __ ] cars
are just sliding
so the grocery trucks they can't even
get on the parking lot
to deliver food so it's not just like a
power issue it's the worst
it's like worse than covid times for
them yeah like when they when we were
all panic buying at the time yeah by
last year like they can't even have way
worse
no i know so so casey's family lives in
dallas right so they've been texting us
and telling us what they've been going
through and
are they gonna fly here just to be safer
i guess i don't know but the air candy
the airplane can't even lift they were
just here
and then they went back they just flew
back just for that crap
yeah oh my gosh and then
and then they're like okay now we know
how to do june b stuff let's go build
out that jumpy in dallas and then
and now they're snowed in so yeah so
then they were telling us like when they
first got like stopped having power it
was like 10 degrees or something
and zero power but luckily his parents
have a gas
fireplace so they were able to have the
fireplace on and they also had a gas
stove so then his brother
and his fiancee had to go over to the
parents house to cook food because they
have an electric stove
with candle light and stuff electric
stove and they're all like wearing like
electrical stuff they look like they're
like the post-apocalyptic world there's
cooking food like oh and then so
carrie ended up sending us a video of
when they went grocery shopping and it's
dark like inside the grocery store
yeah so like they would have like one
light oh like on
in the the front of the store i guess
where the cash would just talk a little
bit but then the rest of the store is
like pitch black and people just have
their cell phones out and it's like
what can they even like buy things with
their credit card
oh it's cash yeah right i don't use i
owe you is like
mary you know me here's what i oh yeah
come find me in like a month
yeah i'll just file that in my little
cabinet though
come back do you see the video of that
girl's fish tank
freezing yeah i saw that it was like i
don't even know how many gallons bro i
was like she's like the fish are dead it
was a giant fish tank and it was frozen
like how cool
if there's no electricity how are they
paying each other if they don't have
cash i know everything
is like or what if your quarters are
[ __ ] froze together yeah venmo
yeah i can't even separate them no but
my friend
you're paying 10 cents then i'm only
paying 4.75
that's it my friends in texas their
instagrams are like i don't know when i
i'm not for a while because i don't know
when i can charge it again
so they're like i need to conserve this
energy yeah so carrie and diana they
were in the car
charging yeah they're sitting in the car
just charging yeah but then it was cute
because
while the car is sliding out of the
driveway
i had to get a car and stuck this uh a
couple of days ago
out of the snow because i was in jersey
yeah and then so my friend had a
um he had to get a bunch of job
interviews done
or like people were doing job interviews
with him in the morning so he was in the
rush
for another zoomb for another junebe but
the diesel truck that we had
i left the key in the car with the light
on so the electricity
was out so he got his dad's camry pulled
it next to it and and
mind you this truck it's it's four wheel
drive but it's in the snow because it's
four-wheel drive i was fine with it
he drove it into it into the snow right
and we tried to charge it up we couldn't
get that car out
and then the truck was still not charged
so we were like [ __ ]
you got two vehicles stuck well he had
he had another car which was a porsche
but it's a two-seater
but he had to go to his like interviews
so he bounced out and it knows me
start with the how come the truck
couldn't start with that there's
actually two
batteries that go into the truck wow and
then we put it in
there's there's two of them one of them
is for the uh it's to like it's for
diesel engines you have to have some
kind of
it's not a spark plug but it keeps the
end like thing warm i forgot the name of
it
yeah but it's like one and then there's
another one and we just had to sit there
and figure out what we're gonna do
and then his dad had to go and get um
this other you know the it's kind of
like a jump starter but it's like a it's
like a machine that you just plug in
like a kit or something yeah it's like a
kit so you had to go to the farm and get
it back
turned on the truck and during this
whole time we tried to just
slide that camry back we had we were
digging in the snow
like man it was nuts we were pushing i
didn't come to jersey for this [ __ ]
but i was having fun yeah this is crazy
i was like this is [ __ ] fun why why
is it so fun and then
he yeah he ended up coming back with
chains and then we got the diesel truck
running
and then we were able to pull it out and
i was like man this is crazy like
it's crazy how like a four-wheel drive
in a two-wheel drive is so
different it's like one you can just
easily get it oh nick looks mind-blowing
yeah i'm just like man that's that's
right
he got you know you got the four-wheel
drive stuck and then they got the camry
stuck and he said [ __ ] y'all i'm not my
porsche
for some people around the country that
occurrence is a daily theme
yeah bro i'd have a panic attack i'd
have a pattern yeah they're just normal
i couldn't do it that's why i would i
would fly to the snow and spend the
weekend and enjoy
and then go home i'm trying to wake up
on monday and be like
yeah no i do i'd be like i ain't trying
to go to work it took us like two hours
to
get maybe like six feet of car distance
i'm done i would be like guess what
throw that car away
i remember i remember last week so uh we
live close to the mountains right
i remember last week we kind of had like
our super mild version of our arctic
blast
and all that was just a little bit frost
on the windshield and i turn on the
windshield wipers and goes
i'm like
damn it la people
suck so bad when it comes to ice and
snow when i was up there looking for
property
and rain wait a second rain every time
it rains i'm like what the [ __ ] is that
i saw so many people sliding and there
was this one car
that slid and slowly hit another car
because they couldn't stop
it was nudged dude did you see that
insane pile up in
in fort worth yeah that was a big rig
right crazy yeah yeah with the big rig
like his brother sent it to him 40 cars
it's a 40 car pile up but it all started
with one truck just like slamming into
the back of another
now there's one that might slam into the
back of another semi yeah the insurance
company's like no
no no it's [ __ ] crazy but it's
nothing you can do when you hit
something like licking your river beard
like here they come
yeah yeah here they come what are you
doing oh no jump out the
[ __ ] car 40 cars dude imagine so what
if
instead of a [ __ ] michael bay movie
you know it looks like a michael bay
movie
that means will smith was driving hey
guys today's video is brought to you by
gabby
when's the last time that you double
check to see
if you're overpaid for auto insurance
because i know you just got a car
yeah i actually used this service to
double check
my payments and how much i could save
and it's
pretty awesome did you find out how much
you would save if you switched
yeah it was probably around 30 bucks a
month
yeah yeah but the thing is i'm getting
rid of my car in a month so
yeah yeah but i mean it's pretty awesome
though because the service
is basically like a search engine right
you put in your information
you know all the stuff for your
insurance and this isn't just for cars
like you could you know get homeowners
insurance and all this stuff
but what i did was i compared it to what
i'm with right now
and i have two cars and i was like if
i wanted to to do this for like the next
three years or whatever
i save 30 to 40 bucks but some people
are saving like 900 something oh damn
yeah so what i like about it the most is
when you're just
googling insurance and comparing
insurance prices a lot of times you'll
get spammed a ton of ads from
all kinds of insurance companies gabby
what's cool about it is you log into
their website and they pull and they
pull all the info
and they do the comparison on there for
you so that you don't get spammed with a
ton of emails so
if this is something that you're
interested in to see if you are indeed
paying the lowest you could be paying
for insurance
gabby is it and what's also cool is they
told us that they
never spam and sell your info so
i thought that was pretty awesome
because that's one of the fears i have
when i sign up for these things is like
man
you just want my data so you can sell my
information
but they're pretty legit and like i said
you know if i was keeping my cars
i'd definitely be switching yeah so
they're totally free
no obligations go to gabby.com
off the record and you can check your
rates to see if you could be saving any
money at all that's gabby.com
off the record g-a-b-i dot com slash off
the record thank you for sponsoring
gabby
so this is this texas ever snow or like
freezer
i mean it does it it gets frosty here
and there but never during christmas by
the way like we texans
always want a white christmas i know
it's never during christmas it's always
in [ __ ] february and we are in
february right now and that's when it
[ __ ] snows but
yeah no like six inches of snow that's
unheard of smells like like
really valentine's white white
valentines white valentine no it did
snow after we got back from new year
like after new year's
like i think a week yeah but it's like
the kind of snow that doesn't stick it's
always the ones like it's snowing and
then it just kind of melts on the floor
i've been in texas where it's cold like
i'm cold yeah i need to wear a puffy
jacket because it's freezing yeah well
that's just a really california thing
for you to say
i don't care if i sound like a like a
little [ __ ] i am a little [ __ ]
i was complaining the other night
because i just wore the vest and not the
whole jacket and i was standing in line
like taco cart in the middle of night
like waiting that line
i'm like i'm so [ __ ] cold i should
have wore the whole jacket but i only
[Laughter]
if you wear a vest and you complain
about the cold that makes you look like
a little [ __ ] because you're wearing
like
the tank top version of a jacket okay
when you left the house you thought you
were so brave didn't you you didn't need
the sleeve
i just need the cord i just got the
decor but you do feel ridiculously warm
when you wear a vest
yeah let's be real i know it's too
uneven for me my back's sweating and my
arms are cold
i have one vest but i just never wear
because every time i wear it it just
feels weird
i love this too what are you wearing
yeah i actually want i got like eight
vests
yeah dude i got like a puffy jacket vest
i got a puffy hair like the
north face i have one of those too but
my back's sweating and my arms are cold
what do you wear with the best
yeah what do you wear with it well the
cool thing with the vest is you're kind
of like make up things you could wear
like say you got like
a shirt on it you could see the the
sweater yeah yeah
and then like different one time you
could do a sweater you could do nothing
like
like i wear t-shirts yeah but i i like
to layer
it with a like a small puffy jacket and
i put the vest over right or denim
jacket sometimes do like the denim
jacket underneath yeah oh that's pretty
tight now or you could put the vest
inside the dinner jack and have
insulation and then have that
because the vest you can also wear with
another jacket on top to have that's
true
it depends on the jacket right there
is it outer vest or like the inner one i
had mine was a puffy one but it was just
my neck got too hot
maybe you don't want the puffy one i got
a i got one of those furry ones with
like the knee against free like north
face furry things that's kind of nice
how's your health as well how do we get
to just talk about i don't know
he's the best because he's cold he
doesn't like the cold
you know i used to hate him i'm filipino
i'm from a i'm a tropical
i i used to hate the cold but i love it
now
now i i wish that things were colder in
l.a
for fashion purposes or for like i think
i didn't really think about fashion but
um i it wakes me up
like it's it's hard to explain like
going outside when it's cold
it feels really think about people that
like cokes i was in that taco line with
my
vest on and i was freezing and then i'm
like gotta go back to the car after i
make my order right do you have mittens
on or
no no no but then there's that one guy
out there with like the shorts and the
slippers on and the thin ass hoodie and
i'm like there's always a guy like that
what is that dude about like what's this
genealogy
that guy's a cop that's you could build
it so i didn't know that you could build
it i don't want it i don't want to build
it you do it it feels good
i don't want to build that be cold
seeing people like that
i'm like you're making me feel amazing
yeah i don't know i did cold training
i've been trying to like welcome the
cold
let me get the shower and like instead
of like hating that it's kind of like
welcome the cold you have to welcome
wake it up like it was by you know
you ever worked out in the cold and your
your body's hot as [ __ ]
but everything else and you started
steaming
so imagine that but not so intense
so it feels good because your body's hot
and warm and then you feel that chill
but you got to work your body to it but
when you get there
it's like oh [ __ ] so this is what my
friends were talking about so
all my fat ass friends this is what they
feel
they run hot they feel warm yeah some
people run hot some people run
like bart and david's always talking
about oh it's too cold it's too
hot man and i was like shut up dude it's
perfect weather
and now i'm like oh i understand why
you're
uncomfortable their body is just
generally hot
they're insulated yeah i've been
swimming sprints in the pool for cardio
and these days the pool is like 40
degrees wow it's
[ __ ] cold yeah yeah the minute you
jump in your nuts [ __ ] hurt and then
i have a like a little time on your body
what happened yeah to go inside your
body it hurts and then i'll do one
sprint and so i'm doing like pretty much
uh every minute on the minute i do a
sprint so i spread for 30 seconds and 30
seconds rest
when i'm resting i have to actually put
my arms
outside of the pool because it hurts
it's so cold that it hurts
and when i'm done swimming when i go and
uh when i go
inside and i look at the mirror my face
is actually frostbitten blue huh it's
red or blue it's red
it's red because it's so um like it got
like it's like putting my face in the
freezer
yeah that's torture does your pool not
heat up i know
it does but it i don't know you feel
like the sense of military or something
ex-military do stuff that we don't right
he was he was supplied
yeah i don't care you still have to go
through like
boot camp and stuff like that yeah yeah
yeah yeah no it just feels good and then
um
but it's crazy because like you actually
get chilled to the core right
and a few hours later you're still like
kind of cold the whole time because it's
all the way down to the bone but then it
feels
really good for some reason it's that
adrenaline temperature thing do you have
them with temperature guns
you should do this oh [ __ ] i should try
it yeah cuz i always say even when
you're saying like
you know all your friends say they run
hot like when you go to the restaurant
they take your temperature i want to see
how hot they're running yeah
if i'm 97 degrees like what are you i
think they're 97 but they know how to
maintain
are they are they 98 they're like oh you
are running
i don't know like 99 borderlands i don't
know if they got a fever inside
do you warm up before you jump in the
pool you just go straight is that the
first thing you do that's the first
thing you cool down
that's really when you get out the pool
when you're like 80 you're like way cold
your whole body is like the temperature
you're about to have hypothermia
no it is cause it'll be like four hours
later and i grabbed geo she's like oh
[ __ ] you're still cold and it's like
four hours later and i've been wearing a
hoodie now have you ever uh
suddenly changed your temperature from
like cold to hot
and it feels like needles in your skin
oh yeah that's crazy
it's crazy to a freezing cold pool
from a normal temperature almost every
time i use the jacuzzi
it's like you know like when your brain
tells you don't do it don't do it yeah
it like i don't know it feels like
someone starts [ __ ] with me so like i'll
be like there i'm like oh i feel so warm
right now i'm like
oh should i jump in the pool i'm like
hell no i should have called this
[ __ ] what'd you say [ __ ] it's
too cold
you think it's too cold in [ __ ]
and i have to go and do it
with your ears
i hate it when there's something that
tells me to do something nice the minute
i have like a little oh really conscious
little [ __ ] i have to go do it my
shit's like you have to
i agree with myself you're right so you
have to investigate with my therapist
get up
get up get out of bed you're like you
should be chilling like you're right i
should probably chill out yeah
it's the opposite you seem a little
tired i
am thank you healthier that's healthier
there's times i'm running right i'm okay
cool like you know
i gotta burn this many calories i'll run
like four miles or whatever right
and then i know which stop sign i have
to turn around at to make it a perfect
four miles because two miles out and
then two miles back
once i get to the stop sign oh thank god
i'm halfway point i'd be like
what i know thank god
hell no you're going another mile that
way i'm like why did i say it
i would do that that's me with pull-ups
all the time because i'm so
into it and then afterwards i get
distracted i'm like oh [ __ ] where was i
at and they're like do it over again
because you forgot it
yeah so you you you can't make up like
like maybe i'm at 30 and i'm like i got
20 more to finish and i'm like [ __ ] did
i did four did i do 40 and they're like
nope you got to start at one and i'm
like
he's talking to you guys man i don't
know but i have the same thing i'm like
oh you're trying to celebrate at the
stop sign
you know what [ __ ] me up is like um i
used to have fast like things right like
as a kid
and then my cousin was uh working out
with me and he was watching me doing
these like little [ __ ] push-ups because
i was like i could do a hundred one two
three four five six seven
and he's like he's just watching me and
then after i'm done he's like you're
only cheating yourself
and i was like [ __ ] i am
i'm the one that don't get the gains
damn
and then so like that just stuck with me
my whole life oh yeah
who's that
real person this time all right all
right
not they just that was a real person
that was a real person yeah i don't know
man we got to investigate this
well you're not trying to do don't you
deal with people who train well you're
trending yeah you are physically always
training also you oh yeah well you know
it's different for everybody right what
do you think about what do you
think about this kind of brain well i
think bart might kill himself one day
but that's fine that'd be fine
but for him it's it works for him you
gotta find what works for you right
everyone's
gonna be a little bit are you happy does
it make you i think david's the other
way
it makes you happy to be hard on
yourself like that when i yeah when it
makes me really happy
that as soon as i feel that there's a
challenge
that i'm never defeated by so i
immediately try to overcome it and then
afterwards
like the days that if like if i do feel
off of this cold i'm not gonna jump in
oh that thought almost plagues me the
whole day like the whole day i'm are you
so you couldn't do that you thought it
was too cold mister
it's just how i think he makes sense of
self-discipline
yeah but then but the days that i just
get it over with you know
did you just start the day off good
though yeah you're like oh you started
off with like
accomplishments but i could get the same
feeling from washing dishes
i do like washing dishes sometimes i
know make your bed in the morning
yes skin's bark skin looks great though
so i think there's something has to do
with that the cold turtle
it looks good i do this russian spot
when we go to spas in my face
it's russian spawn the russian spa is
all about you hit the hot room
yeah they sometimes hit you with the
branch and stuff so get your stuff right
and then you go right jump into the cold
pool
which is like 35 degrees we spot how
long do you stay in there for
like like real quick i can only stand
there for like 30 seconds
right and russians know but there's nba
player guys in there and they were
standing there for like five minutes wow
because that's what they do after every
game i was talking to one of the guys
he's like that's what we do all the time
and then you go that and then you jump i
jump into the regular pool and swim
around and then you just do cycles we
just do cycles of that all day
that's that does not sound relaxing i
feel like i feel like russians
bathe in in ice ponds they know like
they just
what these things is every day [ __ ] you
wear that little weird hat
to keep you in the hot room for longer
if you put this hat on
you could stay in the hot room like five
minutes longer does it got a red star
what does it look like it does one of
them doesn't matter it's just like a
wool hat because it keeps
the heat away from your head i don't
know what it is so you don't get heat
stroke this one girl was like yeah
that's russian girl
you just we we sign on like you
americans
barbecue i'm like okay all right then
let me show you this like
just sitting next to her and she's like
teaching you how to do everything what's
his butt naked next year
no no it's it's it's she had a bikini
you have to wear that
that's co-ed co-ed that's also how like
it's co-ed because you know that korean
spa
it's all dudes it's like you like bye
babe and then you're just
it's a naked guy yeah yeah just hang it
out dude
why is the towel this is the only size
towel i got here yeah
what i ended up that's true i'm like why
is that the only towel can you invest in
bigger towels
i don't care they could see my dick
[Music]
you